want to make money while helping Save a
Life donate your plasma tonight we delve
into who makes a good candidate what it
requires and how much money you can make
in a month
in general we are seeing an increase in
plasma donation there is a critical and
constant need across our country for
plasma donation Dr Mary Keane says the
plasma collected at csl's 320 centers
across the country is used to make
medication for people with rare and
often chronic diseases these are
conditions in which the immune system is
unable to fight off an infection without
assistance there are also people with
bleeding and clotting disorders
including hemophilia people with
inherited respiratory disease plasma
donation is a complex process more time
consuming than donating blood as it
requires separating plasma from the
blood then reinserting the leftover
components into your arm Dr Keane says
your health is not jeopardized by the
amount of plasma taken and your body
replenishes it within 24 hours we look
for people who are in good health be
between the ages of 18 and 74. we ask
that donors weigh at least 110 pounds
donors must have a valid identification
and permanent address also donors must
not have had any tattoos or piercings
done within the past four months prior
to donation Dr Keane says with covid-19
a lot of people developed an awareness
of plasma donation for the first time
the number of donors is now picking back
up this could be in part because people
appreciate the payment and it helps out
with expenses additionally we see
seasonal influxes with people returning
from summer break or winter break
through college campuses so just how
much can one make while donating plasma
it varies by city but right now people
can look at and expect about five
hundred dollars for their first month's
donation as a qualified
there are five Las Vegas CSL plasma
centers one in Henderson they are open
seven days a week a person can donate up
to two times in one week and again make
about five hundred dollars for a month's
worth of donations